come into this twitch stream here we go
again I'm going to join the all of these
super blitz let's do it right now okay a
little bit of an what is that can cut
afternoon
what is 2:00 p.m. I said still noon noon
ish or are we already talking about the
afternoon anyway I got tea ready and
I've got middle time like one hour maybe
a little bit more after that I have to
do with the bloody Texas ah so I felt
yeah let's go for what tournament first
ten get some nine eight seven six five
four three okay what's going on here
Tyreke I'm not going to berserk this
tournament yeah I tried this beserk
every game and well yeah it was really
hectic so I'm just going to play normal
game sets in anybody already around in
the chitlin I don't see any message and
huh what's that like didn't whoa okay um
yeah go to cool pond first check message
in yeah somehow I got two points just
like that I don't know why but well I'll
take it easy and amelie on and again I'm
trying Knight to f3 and play a rather
conservative Ordnung
okay that's already
that can get can get shop get into
proper play mode the mutiny of the
bounty the funny name so let's go with
g4 if he takes it I've owned a piece
with Quint a flaw which is admittedly
rather easy to spot but it's still not
bad anyway without strife coming I think
Opera is correct but I keep forgetting
the theory even though I play I'm
playing this for four years young and
still keep forgetting how the exact
theory runs hello to fame and you're
always around ended here no sir in those
broadcasts that's cool but what are you
doing all day I'm not studying anymore
Oh what are you doing so let's see ok
this looks interesting
ok I'm going to have winning a piece of
course but things are things are
complicated when I was rather expecting
Bishop g3 to happen ok huh I wonder
what's best to it so I mean white must
be better here but it's still a position
and it's not super simple at least for
somebody like me with I'm getting
notoriously nervous if my king is yeah
under under Sun and there's some
pressure
[Music]
okay you get a notification on your
phone when I'm online that's cool
maybe okay so again I'm a piece up and
[Music]
the bishop on g3 is way isn't going
hello to mercury and to jaeseok his work
any is anybody around with a
subscription Fame in you I am right I've
I have submitted this emote I can't go
for one email currently with my with my
own my kind of subscription or
subscriber base but somehow it's still
under it is pending I wonder if I'm
doing something wrong there okay I'm
happy to see the trade on c6 that is
strengthening my Center hello too freaky
I really like the folks yeah it's it's
really cool somehow if I go Knight h5 I
have a double threat yeah this is a
double threat yeah he did not really
reacted 92 was the move but then I take
a - okay so you heard that waiting it's
not uncommon
I mean that emote that are submitted is
really nothing it shouldn't be critical
in any way okay I'm winning lots of
material him
you know there's nothing nothing special
but I still hope people will like it
it's one of the perks of being a
subscriber I don't I don't I have not
yet decided what else to do with the
subscribers that same or like there are
us there are some things there are some
things that she can do they how
subscriber only like subscriber only
chance or things like that I mean I have
to think about it okay so this is going
to be funny because I can do this now
play the album count again but um no
don't think so the opening is a bit too
bad no that's not what I guess I think a
lake is a process a pretty common name
g3 is a funny moving out by the way
okay so I can take now on g3 or an f2
and on h2 1 f2
[Music]
yeah Moreau's which played it but it's
still a terrible opening I always get
that argument that murasa which played
it and it really is pointless he played
it
thank you know 15 years ago and that's a
real that's a real difference nowadays
you just switch on the engine and it
tells you many ways to play to play for
huge advantage for what okay so how am I
going to play it Queen to g7 probably a
material down but the night is somewhat
oh it just gives it to me your sample
Lauren strong played it the the Albin's
yeah I know it is something people do
this sometimes as price weapons and of
course let's say in a course of a rather
casual blitz game okay you can do it but
yeah I don't think it's it's really good
opening I was surprised that not too
long ago when he came in Belgium it was
played by Grandmaster against a fellow
Grandmaster and unsurprisingly Black was
completely completely screwed after like
I don't know 10 moves but somehow
swindle to draw okay this is going to be
made on h2 is wait and meet nice one
young
buna beaches okay let's cool what did
that flavor just oh we need to go I
think so yeah well I guess that's not
really a sword itches I know there's
always some entertainment value about
those games but I can assure you that I
still do this Oh every time I get I get
paid padding and sympathize playing on
the s-e-c it just it's not a very
enjoyable experience
qui to e8 okay well I go to 5h for wines
on age six that helped me tremendously
Adi gas is an international master and
very strong blitz player who is playing
on the ISIS irregularly and he's not
particularly popular with most people I
have a funny idea how to checkmate blank
that's right we should be to Queen g6
and then for Bishop h5 maid
okay I mean no I'm not not playing
tournaments so no chance to get a
grandmaster norm but it's also no I mean
I just don't have the plane level I have
to I would have to work a lot which I
don't really have time for or want to do
mmm I was mmm he prevented this this
made that I was after I have a Wikipedia
page no need to creat create it I have
won three years in English and German
made right yes it could be updated I
think the Wikipedia page but
it's not a really super important I
think it's it's nice to to be on there
but it's not super important for me so
fast and furious is not playing hello
new Royden thanks for subscribing there
is no English page okay I don't know I
haven't looked at it for a while I just
OH
24 yeah okay probably simply taking as
good
fast and furious so if I if I tell you
that I have never ever seen a single one
of those movies that's making me an
equal person it's something that is that
I should definitely change
homina Feliz is one of the more
difficult languages I would say probably
there are more difficult ones but I
think it's it's quite tricky because of
because of many exceptions and
irregularities let's say so you think I
don't miss much if I don't know any of
the Fast and the Furious movies okay
yeah I mean there are some things that
are not necessarily great but they're
there somehow I think no I don't know a
part of pop culture yeah like kids
sometimes I think you should have maybe
seen it just you know what what it's
about yeah and let's say you can you can
argue that no Star Wars isn't exactly
yeah great art or something but it's
something that is part of modern pop
culture
I'd like to mmm there are all those pins
YUM
this should win some material light I
think we should take slight extra
penalty to
oh yes this is problem
yeah this is I said saving some material
I have a hard time to believe it Bishop
g4 would have been better there that's a
good hint would have been better
indeed yeah this is this is actually not
super great I also haven't seen any of
the Transformers movies not a single one
okay
yeah King c2 and I always played that
quite quite a bit and all that
transformers we had there of those toys
when I was a kid and I always felt that
it was extremely lame
yeah I think I'm winning some material
after all miss play dead quite badly
covering c-7 matt peake for the
candidate zoom yeah I don't go in the
room yet how does he keep policy captain
weird
yeah I saw that it had to speed up so I
went for one pre moves I have to get the
viewercount into the stream setup again
now that I'm streaming with the OBS OBS
does not display the view count and I
would like to see how many many are on
master Marik Adam Sandler adaptation is
there any good film with Adam Sandler
probably not yeah Bishop III is the key
idea trying to get some pieces and
uncomfortable spot how is Nakamura are
not in the candidates yeah how exactly
him didn't qualify you don't get there
by him I don't know by coincidence and
they were quite a number of ways to
qualify but he didn't make any of it
didn't do rating didn't do it by rating
he didn't get anywhere in the World Cup
or in the Grand Prix I think he wasn't
close early in any any sort of way to
qualify and it's difficult I mean
they're just eight places so there are
some some really strong people missing
notably um BL
[Music]
yak will be one one to activate the
Queen punch-drunk love with ants and I
haven't seen and one of bottoms and this
is usually quite good right even though
I think but I really actually only saw
him the first one Boogie Nights okay so
I have to reconsider my bishop placement
many Bishop takes e4 is actually a move
as Queen takes interesting interesting
mmm I can't have to go on full full
blockade
phantom threads back portals and oh yeah
haven't been much to the movies in
recent years behind cicadas good move by
master Marik so going to be three if not
I think actually okay one is the better
choice
try Jerry trying to put more pressure
but here I don't really see a great
continuation if you heard of cheese many
is no idea
probably even pronouncing it in the
wrong way so mocking nb6 quite a bit but
if antique it means okay yeah I know I
know what it is basic leave it it's not
something that I there's but part of my
regular vocabulary
[Music]
I can't even see your eyes with this
crap we and that took some hand gamble I
know what this premium quit if I see one
was failure
yeah but against its what happens there
the cakes was recently played against me
d5 and then they sacrificed inform that
was I was extremely disconcerting ok so
I think this
I know P sauce has this stuff I keep
forgetting ready
no I'm drinking team wash
okay hmm that's fairly annoying or a
limb to get Bishop a six and I have to
get rid of my Bishop on b7 it's just the
worst yeah probably I should I shouldn't
play this line I mean Bishop f6 is just
good for a language instead of 95 but
it's often avoided because of them yeah
the position some are slightly tricky so
yeah I'm just doing okay I mean the
opening is not good but he played
totally fine after that my a pawn is
worth absolutely nothing really nothing
no I'm not drawing come on
no no need to draw that looks iffy
anyway that was my plan now getting it
back yeah that's not the greatest end
game ever but yeah what can you do
why is that win only by swindle I don't
I don't get it I'm just playing this
ending and there are some some ideas
here for for me it's probably a draw
offered three minute madness you want to
want to see return this format of me
playing three minutes chests and playing
somewhat wiki openings is certainly
enjoyable something to think about you
know I'm getting somewhere here this
Wonder blunder he had trouble keeping
keeping things together it's still not
an easy window anything for me but at
least that's two pawns and
yeah if I take it I can probably just
run over the way hmm it's not not super
easy I know it's a bit wacky not to
exchange but I go around us everyone
I wasn't totally totally sure if this is
a super easy win I probably should have
done it though I know I'm not oh let's
mate mate it's crazy that's crazy
right to me yeah I should have traded of
course oh man I was funky and I won
second place how did that happen and
your office a good tactic it's it costs
a bit of time for me yeah the king of
porn handing it it is ladies it is a win
I guess but I wasn't totally sure I
wasn't totally sure they were king e7 e
goes to d5 place f4 and I'm losing the
six yeah I mean they are usually a win
but I was irritated at the moment
so get a fairly close position here and
now we'll play for a five
yeah sometimes weird things happen with
with resigning and room making drawers
when you are in venue and sometime time
issues I once had a situation in our on
the ICC that was a wait
that was long before my channel was was
started when I was playing in I was
playing in one of those tournaments and
they had there was like in the in the
early 2000s when there was the dos dos
hermanas internet tournaments and I
played quite well somehow and got to
play Alexi Draya and he's a very strong
Russian Grandmaster yes best rating was
were close to the 2700 say he was a it
wasn't the candidates matches for
example anyway I played this game and we
reached them drawn ending something
where nothing was happening
nothing yeah and then I wanted to offer
a draw and instead yeah I resigned this
is completely crazy and in fact that was
only Isis Eve I had to confirm the
resignation and I confidently clicked do
you want to resign yes and then I
resigned and all of a sudden like why
did I resign it was one of us completely
idiotic moments where you feel like yeah
you should someone and they should take
away your your basic yeah rights you
know basic rights like you're voting and
driving your car whatever you should
simply be put out of business to do
anything
was completely crazy and yeah good
question by J page should you get a
starter package or should you get some
some other package of chess bass
well I think that you can you can really
go by just going with the starter
package I would actually get the
download version of chess space if you
really decide to get it and you are sure
about getting it to get the wait get the
download version this is I think in 99
dollars or 99 euros it's not it and
euros I think maybe it's a bit more in
dollar I don't know it is a full of
program that you need and then you need
to get some good data base to to do the
the data mining with but those are
easily available for download and there
are many many free databases as you that
you can can use download and be fully
equipped with everything that you need
okay I don't like how I played this
maybe I should have taken on c6 but yeah
it's it's why it is so three maybe it's
not the greatest position over here
I need to open this up so we get an open
Sicilian after all we takes with the
Queen I was more expecting to take with
the pawn who's xx x 3 3 3 mmm
who is there dude what's his name yeah
there are huge databases of computer
games well oh yeah this is a I don't
know I don't post that but it could be
useful maybe you also know where where
could I get the good correspondence game
database that feelin field would be
really helpful but I have no clue where
to where to get one I recently I
recently got a new book about the about
ready airplane and the system this book
uses correspondence games a lot and they
really exceptionally high quality my
understandable and they would use
computer computers extensively and this
way I'm there they probably make very
good reference material for brain books
yeah I was thinking that this isn't good
you 295 but
wrong let's do it
meet on g7 is the threat I already see
what he does he 7 Hank's made on g7
takes b2 I take his 7 with chick so
looks all cotton so here I'm going to
take the night first now if he takes on
d5 at 8:00 with the bishop and a much
better
okay and now Knight f6 is getting
interesting should I should shouldn't I
should have played 97 immediately that
was bad that was bad pretty bad
pretty bad and then 138 seconds that's
not a comfortable time distribution I
had 97 I was I was really not thinking
about this too clearly challenges after
the arena I haven't thought about it
yeah maybe
let's do with some challenges after the
arena blundering this freaking pawn and
I'm getting I'm getting annoyed by this
game I already had a clear win and
didn't didn't do it very unnecessary at
all
97 before was was just completely over
seven seconds okay we hello - Tara to
him thank you
okay five points behind leg Nam that's
not going to be easy okay
yeah I know which is paid cells this
correspondence database for a silly
silly amount of money and I am not
willing to pay that I felt there should
be something available for free
oh my god that doesn't look good
I'm trying to play this quickly
rookie 185 medium this is also strong
gee page us how did I determine my rates
for private students yeah mostly
comparison with other guys charge okay
so that was one reason to be quick
no stop fish could not defend this
position and it's not if you give white
a bit of time in the bonnet game maybe
but not in not in anything with time for
white like c5 a plate is attached to
quickly
it's pretty awful for what disposition
yeah thanks for subscribing okay this is
this night f5 is an annoyance why I
don't like to take
I didn't like to take this orally and I
can maybe dig and play with with the
discovery here he basically blundered
the exchange but it's so not completely
simple yes to check
g4 is an interesting idea let's do it
like tweenage look h1 and get get into
attacking position with the rook yeah I
can take b6 and go to d5 but by now my
look is so active shouldn't have done
that
okay well now he's got no move the
bishop cannot move his roots if you made
you cannot prevent it okay I'm doing
okay it's not like I'm playing
completely badly here but leg Nuys
winning and winning and winning and I
don't get paid against him yeah that's
that's yeah I think you're pretty equal
it's the usually more available under
Bishop g5 could could happen oh yeah and
I'm not so happy with this oh just a
second that was the doorbell okay so
let's go here yeah yesterday it wasn't a
good session at the Benton session on
the only ICC under on chest 24 I'm sorry
about yeah I'm always I had this
connection issues and I'm always
irritated by that mightily early or more
than has should be irritated but I'm
terribly irritated like I'm staring yeah
there is this the statistic about two
lost frames and I'm staring at that the
whole time them completely mmm I'm
completely irritated yeah this is a
completely equal ending of course not
much to do
I don't know is it a good strategy to to
just draw this game and go for the next
I wonder
that's very equal very equal no I'm
sorry I'm not married okay alright so
this is not not much hey to put it
lightly
drinking tea yeah okay so I have this I
mean a little bit quicker we're here on
the g5 it instead of course extremely
dry I should be 500g one I can travel g
6h 6 and the King long go to g3 yeah
still drawn it still dry let's same
this is me a way to induce something
rookie 5 a guru ji 1 for Luke C 1 and
now I have aged 43 King a 5 there's
always Ruby 5 so I'm not getting
anywhere about this I believe
ok inch from this is now slightly
interesting okay this one I should have
come to this this anyway and what I'm
better than Ruby 7
[Music]
I'm not getting anywhere
no I don't want to make draw him
maybe this is something to try and no
it's probably still it wrong that is to
draw
yeah hmm so our stuff
I was just gambling ring yeah I don't I
also don't think that meth and chess are
so I'm super related people who are good
at math can be good at chess and vice
versa which is nothing and something
like what is this guy doing like playing
every move in a split second but knows
this inside our it seems and I'm playing
am playing this really terribly
pretty awful maybe should be five would
give me some chances but you will
probably prevent it crap I hate it I
want it what a crap game that was really
bad
that was really bad and it wasn't it was
an opportunity rid him he had to had to
stumble into someone places really well
ah else it wasn't good
[Music]
have you heard of Alou meter calm nope I
don't know yeah I'm well
but like no I really cannot really think
it started there with the drawing then
one the rest problem very well deserved
um tournament victory I guess yeah we
would have won that game would have been
sure to shared first but that's a kind
of irrelevant so who is on yeah let's do
it from top to bottom yah go 100 yeah go
should play them going for benoni yeah
Tom I see you I will next the next in
line
so we transpose to an English opening
Queen in five then dear okay this is
actually blundering d4 no let's take
this first
yeah I don't know you know meter hmm I
mean if I want to know what my ello is I
look at the rating last so you ready
lists came out today I guess lost a
couple of points they had my tournament
in Cracow rated then lost nine points
them yeah I was able to take before and
hmm - one is out of out of wits him
and to two pieces up okay so thanks for
the game behind over 100 so Tom what
seemed a upon Sione Akuma voice the best
line this is probably equal many other
lines in the pantheon II white is
fighting for equality quite quite hard
it looks dubious what is White's idea
okay so maybe just Bishop to d7 or is
there something better
mmm the three blunders in four
yes so if I just take why just coverage
let's cover it and prepare Knight f6
I'm okay I'm happy to trade to an ending
where I'm up sent up horn you know that
looks pretty nice
the idea is to prevent him from
developing it cannot move the night 93
but that's not something you are
particularly afraid of 92 a key T is 3
and T 2 almost has to play before and
now 92 there's F 1 F 1
[Music]
yeah I can take I think because I can
take d4 next yeah thanks for the game
Tom yeah I think in the pantheon II here
you have to Queen a form with oops
I cannot scroll up to to dump yeah here
you essentially have to go d3 Queen c2
and play basically like a filly the one
philidor's colors reversal that's the
best and white can get in the Ponciano
okay don't read this yeah but you know
okay once you read it it doesn't work
out right so we have to read it to know
that you don't have to read it anyway
playing the chairman income the exchange
slide explode the exchange
Slav always enjoyable for black it's not
that bad
maybe you can maybe I can create some
sort of green fealty a few go c4 but she
doesn't know it looks okay the seep one
is backward
[Music]
not easier
not sure about this does Germany have a
state of state tap of speech like the US
no I don't think something that you can
so easily compare but I think them the
German Chancellor set the right
pronunciation
we have those addresses to the
Parliament that that are done I'm not
sure what how often does this happens
where they but they usually have a topic
yeah it's not something general yeah
folks yeah you're right it's exactly
what I played I have to say though I'm
not completely sure that it is good but
my ideas rookie ain't okay was rupee
eight bishop athlete but this is not
[Music]
hmm it's not so bad might be three to c5
is definitely an idea for white yeah
numero it said as an American we could
learn from Germany in many ways I think
it's actually there are many things
where you should actually try to be not
not you I think people in general should
just view every every nation in a more
than safe not not sure what the right
word is but yeah there's there's
something to learn from from from
anybody
yeah everybody has them yes there every
nation has things they they do do
perfectly well where we can learn from
them and some other things are not great
it's not that there's I don't know let's
say yeah I'm just just for an example
yeah it's not like like Norway is doing
everything right yeah and and the u.s.
is doing everything wrong or something
like that for example if you if you
think about the United States think well
Germany could learn from the vs s in
many cases and in Germany we are very
concerned often about things they're
like yeah can you or let's say is this
it's possible to yeah to wreck this
building exactly a displays or yeah has
there been let's say some sort of thing
happening 300 years ago so that we
cannot do it whatever yeah we we tend to
talk about stuff like for ages and every
single little thing has to be checked to
ten times and so on and I think
sometimes you just have to do stuff and
not I mean talk about everything so much
this always drove me crazy when I was
working
still in the office yeah that there
would be people who would like like
talked for ages and ages and ages and if
they would actually need to do some
things like ah no we have to do this
again and whatever terrible absolutely
terrible and this is for example a
spirit that is I think much better in
the u.s. they at one point they just say
okay we get rid of this crap and we do
it right there and do it new these this
kind of this kind of attitude is
something that I think would be very
useful in Germany sometimes so a four
yeah I give up the exchange and felt
wait I can't do this Queen a six and
then before now that actually don't work
it does not work I came and he took this
yeah this is this is some kind of true I
think Germans tend to follow rules quite
um quite strictly that's true but it's
also this this constant need of talking
about stuff yeah like how we need to
reconcile this with everybody and blah
blah blah yeah just do stuff if it needs
to be done do it and this is sometimes
pretty it can be really really annoying
[Music]
okay
rooks Queen Queen d6 a very well played
game but don't read this Bishop c5 oh
now we know he gives me stuff the moment
has seemed I say that it's playing it
well he burned us the house it was
really well played before there yeah
thanks for the game don't reads us again
very well played so yeah hi jinks
Stadium I really jinxed it playing a
slightly irregular opening he 496 it's
not too bad yeah this this looks nice
for example
okay now that I think of it I did not
really need that not really needs to
prevent you should be five okay person I
just played them is in the chat just a
different different name
yeah here I'm going to try for an early
King side attack with g5 this is some
this is not too bad the center is quite
close and rook g8 is coming inside it
talks dangerous this Bishop on a7 is
extremely strong at least as long as
white is not going c4 to c5 if he goes
c5 he's going to yeah blunt this piece
and now that I think of it if he's ended
in the Twitter stream he might read what
I'm saying
[Laughter]
but hooray I think I'm I don't need the
h-bomb as mentioned in the in the chat I
can't well this is five plus three is
actually too long hmm
I didn't really look at this too closely
but five plus three is a bit too long in
those he in his form and I'd like to
keep it a little bit quicker
I was only realizing that the moment as
I looked at my clock and it's on five
ten
yeah f 2 and H 2 this is really a
problem night at 3 I can take F 2
I have won an exchange
there's no checkmate anymore but
exchange has has to be enough
oh do you have a Family Guy TV show in
Germany I don't know the show that
you're referring to I know that exists I
heard of it but I've never watched it
and German TV no I absolutely don't
watch TV arrow
in Germany we usually dump the shows and
it's terrible this is a reason why I
never watched geometry the the shows
that are actually produced in Germany in
German language they know they usually
suck there's like one or two exceptions
but they usually suck and yeah if you
try to watch something like Big Bang
Theory with German with German dub it's
it's this is the worst the absolute
worst so we know to know what the King
Bota your challenge is still on the list
as you see a double fake arrow
plain that a lot internally chance of
brilliant d6 or not c6 and one time
entertainment was the largest US export
I'm not sure if that's still true yeah
probably
nowadays the largest US export yeah I
know Trump jokes maybe like it's cable
25
thanks for the subscription do Germans
usually speak English very well
hmm I think our level is generally it's
not as good as for example the
Scandinavian countries on on the
Netherlands I think one one of the
reasons is actually that they don't want
to tap the TV shows now this is some if
they feel on one part of it but I think
the Germans are getting better what is
really sometimes sometimes difficult is
the German accent I know that I have an
in German accent but I don't feel it's
super terrible but some Germans really
have have issues with their their
accents that they're they're really
really tough but I think most of the
time they are not too bad in terms of
grammar or vocabulary
so we should age three I don't know if
that was such a great decision
now they not think of it
hmm g5
he threatened to open this up what city
you live in
yeah it's a small it's a small town
basically I live in Dean slacking which
is near Goose book and Dusseldorf which
you maybe have heard of also not too far
away from Cologne which is also a
well-known city or don't do it maybe the
football soccer persons um okay so what
to do now let's go try for Bishop f4
now I have not watched the men in the
high castle I know it's an Amazon TV
show right I felt that what I read about
it is interesting I like them I like
those alternative history plots I think
it's interesting tough let's go here no
I'm not going to play the monthly record
tournament at six o'clock no chance I
have to stop the stream in about half an
hour and then invest quite a bit of time
in my Texas unfortunately so yeah who
said that matrix drawn says I was born
into Saddam and that is why they call me
raw yeah I know that that's from the
producers of course I watched the remake
and original from 1968 and I really
think the original was better I don't
think they did a terrible job with the
with the remake but I still feel the
original was was great
[Music]
yeah I don't think I have a good
position here it looks it looks very
shaky but Lord Kinbote in its investing
quite a bit of time and doesn't seem to
come up with much maybe I could have
played that is six actually I probably
could have done that
[Music]
gather the men in the high castle is by
originally by philip k dick right
Oh is Alexa Davalos I don't know her I
think an excess probably all right now I
don't know okay I'm looking at g6 what
time is the spire a 5-0 no increment
Knight comes to e5 that looks like a pin
really awkward pin
I know how does he save it him I don't
think you can yeah thanks forgive me
Lord Kinbote er I think you had a good
position there it must have been good
for you
so yeah five plus one is it too long I'd
like I'd like to have it maybe we
challenge like 4 plus 1 3 plus 2
something like that
Neph you're off pin F you're off nephew
enough doesn't seem to play no he does
okay and then it's not bad that line for
white but it's a little bit more on just
a little bit yeah three plus two is good
I just feel it should be something like
that so that more people get the
opportunity to play
case Wayne Bishop to b3 I was thinking
this could be an idea and then f6 if I
planned some tournaments like the yearly
super blitz or something else yeah if it
fits into my schedule I will definitely
do some something like that but I have
to check out also I want to install at
least one more one more weekly show with
the the reliable time slot let's say and
I have to think about this when would be
a good a good time for that I don't like
that he plays but should be three and in
the nearest future here not much that I
can do about it
yeah three plus two is five that's a
good statement in the chat but I still
feel like what is that court like the
Fields Medal or something like that is
that that lettuce that's the famous meth
price right it won't get that in for
three plus two is five maybe if you
prove that this is wrong when did I
become an international master in 20
2012
it took me it took me a long time and
yeah I definitely know that I could have
done it quicker and it wouldn't have
been that difficult but I made make
things difficult a little bit didn't I
did not play I did not play open
tournaments I just played the team and
team events and and those I always
became close to score I am knows but
always there was just to have a point
lacking in more than one occasion I
never would have played some open
tournaments I probably would have gotten
it a lot quicker
when office draw
I'm still trying to win this game even
though it is equal g3 night 895 yeah the
crazy house is an interesting chess
variant I don't like those completely
weird things like I don't know how hot
or something like that but the crazy
house is quite okay you can it's
entertainment but I still think you you
practice tactics away 90 x f3 is a fancy
move and then take on g2 yeah that was
the idea
okay so thanks for the game P nephew
Olaf game move always yep da check yeah
but I can take it
let's do something out there usually
play the scotch scotch four nights
[Music]
good player by game over always go to
bring play awesome
transposition into a pot fitted or a
type of game I wonder him if I can just
one it's my idea
p6o alright looks good for white knight
on f5 this is going to be dangerous
maybe Bishop takes h6 is already a
problem possibility and yeah why not
let's take it pawn takes and Queen d2
how are you surviving this I don't think
that works for for him
and mate that that's going to be tough
too
tough to defend maybe you can defend it
but it looks very difficult to do so
this is one one way of trying so I take
it
so there's Bishop g7 but then I can take
and play 95 so let's get rook the rook
in the game this is the idea
yay again this Knight g5 should do the
trick
it was an additional idea I don't think
it was defendable that looks it looked
like too much maybe after Bishop takes
h6 there was decaying C form something
like that but here Queen - Queen h8
looks absolutely absolutely deadly
almost supremo yeah thanks to the game
game over always so f6 never service was
still too much okay SC car skal not
playing move I'm approaching 2000 from
2300 Oh Queen g7 mate okay yes yes yes
yes of course there was psyllium I could
have made it in one move no currently
not accepting new students
[Music]
yeah the funny line this Bishop takes c3
leading to very unconventional positions
before as an interesting gambit idea
against it there's also g4 I think yeah
Knight f6 I guess and what IH didn't
start playing chess seriously at age 13
which is very late
Bach was
[Music]
so you
so I mean if I was thinking that taking
money for AI is probably very risky
quintics quincy freaking of true ma'am
very risky it's developing the idea
three my idea was Knight to g4 but I
have no real idea about this opening I
was just playing it for the sake of
doing something else most of you and
it's really not easy
my idea was 94 no but I'm blundering we
should be seven Wow then my position
sucks absolutely sucks
oh wow sometimes if I mean so such a bad
position like this I'm I really feel
like that some physical pain yeah like
oh it hurts it really hurts
well I wanted to play nights you for put
a night on to you five but it takes a
long one
just taking looks good
you know I have not heard of Graham's
number I have no idea what to say what
that is something mathematical I assume
really my math knowledge is not great I
mean I had meth till until the final
final exams at school but after that not
much and they've forgotten absolutely
everything that is somewhat
sophisticated at this such a terrible
position and it's three plus two so I
cannot even win on time that happens
them when you need to try something out
of the ordinary
it's cool that I get more math questions
yeah that I can talk about yeah great
this position is great what a bad
position cannot cannot even simplify
them
but it's important more for chess or
math now that that's not a real question
I think there's a word missing somewhere
I can take it right let's take it Queen
f3 I can go back yeah Queen f3 checkers
almost mandatory
it's still not an easy task absolutely
not
it's probably dry
not good all this so I'm not getting
checkmated anymore does it some good new
preventing king of three okay okay I've
got a better ending now at least
yeah I think I need to be able to okay I
know I'm winning the five I think I
don't know I know but you might get the
h-bomb
and don't think I'm getting in so strong
but if he takes on your six yeah very
good game here by SCC our skull Oh tough
so who else is on [ __ ] bukakke
enforcer I don't know so roughly two
hours is the same time that I'm going
for so
[ __ ] enforcer okay but tank is a
[ __ ] enforcer anyway
I don't think like is an engine and we
approaching the kind of position where I
would maybe be an angular engine
okay
I mean okay
many mooseville would be very good let's
aim
no tournament coming up I need to stop
the stream in roughly ten minutes
yeah you know I don't really want to do
this Texas stuff but I have to
yeah thanks for the game beep okay so
one or two more things
chewy how many of us do we have at the
moment I should get that plug-in again
107 okay it's not too bad 117
jitteriness isn't playing okay LIF what
above 100 is it's quite good
okay I'll bore them don't draw with
Becky two plus three haven't done this
for a long time
Queen f3 is since kind of odd maybe I
can play with f5
a push for F no I can't I can try to get
on those weekend squares ok ok no no
this is going to be annoying yeah so
let's do this
threatening to take on a form that looks
looks shaky this position looks shaky
night C 5 is the most normal maybe it
checks on F 3 D 3 it looks like there
should be something
okay I'm not sure
and why is losing lots of time so try to
open it up yeah I can take twice only
form twin takes Bishop g5
his name is drawn with black but I
wouldn't be happy with the draw anymore
I have to admit I see a maid coming up I
can take it I'm such a [ __ ]
ah ah you can take the thing ah
that was stupid I mean I'm better still
but I was thinking like move that night
III check King he one Bishop b3 made and
yeah I could have played that 92 to him
to get the same thing that would have
won the Queen at least I mean this is
not not bad him but bad it's not bad but
the game sort of continues and it
shouldn't oh now I miss Knight to f5 oh
my god I Knight to a5 Knight to a5 o
Queen a7 is saving me there was close
yeah knife f5
I'm miss playing this what quietly okay
ng6 I don't like a knight aged six looks
look bad
how to checkmate him that's the whole
question I'm getting out of this chicken
Queen a1 yep okay yeah I think I think
it was impossible to prevent radium and
nope I don't have a job in addition to
chess
oh no joke chess is on having an early
morning session 10:00 a.m. right
maybe I know no joke urine urine no joke
em you're an expert here on twitch
things how long does it take until my
emote is approved it is so pending the
one that is submitted
a few days yeah okay I submitted it I
think what is that Thursday at two days
ago
okay no it's not it what I guess emote
should keep those form for later if I
saw this correctly I'm only allowed one
emote anyway and subscriber batch okay
so the little purple star can be
something something else okay well it's
good it's good it was I mean I don't
know those things I don't think they are
very young
yeah some of those things are not really
intuitive check on v3
yeah they're probably somewhere in them
there's probably some sort of manual
somewhere and but when you start
twitching you don't normally get get
this explained to you but things are
shaping up nicely I'm like 1 1 or 2 days
away from partners they stay as status I
don't actually know what that means if I
have a real this really means something
I know that the affiliate allowed them
allowed the subscriptions and that's
what I understood but I don't know
exactly what what the partner thing does
whenever they place Queeny for you think
of 94 but doesn't really work yeah I
haven't looked into it I mean what this
partner status is doing Bishop c6 I mean
you're when you are in the in the twitch
dashboard you get they they they show
you your progress there with percentage
to partner stuff like that but I did not
really
I did not really look into it I figured
things for how this is man night things
were sort of become clearer later
yeah that's that's a moment where you
feel
yeah I think I'm not sure what this
position was it looked okay for white
for sure I let's to that said that I
read about that as a partner you can you
can store and videos longer that's true
I can't probably this is good now you
can take c6 but I'll triple triple on a
farm
Bishop c5 is a bit annoying okay so here
threatening book takes is free now I
don't know how many videos I can store
at the moment I mean it all gets to
YouTube so root cakes III I wanted to
play that No okay yeah thanks for the
game David yeah I wonder I can I can
play didn't-didn't up late yah go
already
I don't remember
I have played him once dreams for sure
yeah yes no joke is watching I have to
play one other cards at least
I keep getting that move I never never
and they don't remember what is good
about it
well it's good against it this is the
correct way of phrasing it
so he chase I take on e5 and he will
take on b7 now that it's not super
convincing but just each six maybe
Oh so all this thought was for naught
yep it's a good night yeah maybe we'll
get de for my development is pretty good
now he's movin screen around at song no
it's that should not be bad
1394 I have one standard problem in this
opening is the night won't be six
it really isn't well placed so I try to
improve it the other way of doing it
would have been maybe C 6 or 6 but 95
looks fine
or maybe night to see 5 in some cases
okay yeah it's kind of an x-ray this
side it always okay so what about this
I I don't think he gives me the might
I didn't give up on YouTube I mean
there's more YouTube videos than ever
I'm just producing them on Twitch I
think it's it's also more fun to me to
do the videos while there is a live
audience
it's simply what I recognized as I
sometimes try to like sit down and make
videos and it's just more fun if you
just go online and have some chat and so
on it's it's just a lot more not more
entertaining for me then sitting then to
produce the videos while I'm yeah
basically not communicating at all I
feel this is more enjoyable it's also
nicer to have a little bit of it's nice
to have some immediate feedback and in
some cases so like you get subscriptions
or people with Chia we didn't have a
single Chia in the session which is not
so bright but it's nice even if you you
get some cheering bits and you get a bit
of money and it's not like yes yeah yeah
it's it's just fun that you that you get
those those things Oh again yeah okay
it's not it's not like I'm starting to
yeah starting to take over halfway up by
buying stocks from all those
Cheers but it's so cool okay
so thanks for the game yaga 100 so yeah
yeah I know maybe I will stream a little
bit longer I really have to do the Texas
but I can do it a bit later okay
yeah while I have completely forgotten
the move orders him
yeah subscriptions of course better than
she is but yeah gia the seeds huh
I had something today just wanted to get
a sandwich at my local bakery and they
only had she something but it was okay
it was quite quite taste him so I can
take a 95 play 95 immediately I think
I'm taking not totally sure about it
no solando okay so yeah I think in order
to cheer you have to buy those bits em
but again this is not my area of
expertise oh really
I forgot this ah I forgot about this
book stupid stupid stupid
wha I came in
I'm not happy about this
I just played that quite a bit I have to
break this pawn his pawns there was
still some scenario was where I would be
a little bit better for example if he
takes on a form which she does not do
okay
well I'm giving up the exchange why not
with them with
[Music]
this strong bishop and the people I'm
fine
I wanted to play Bishop c6 but it
doesn't work okay no this is this is
also not terrible this is helpful should
to have seven and to pick up everything
Keys trying to get to eat room I can go
with these six
what down on the first rank has also
would be very serious yeah yeah I can't
do this
yeah I think I'm okay let's put this on
square and it's covered
the two pawns should be should be enough
f/4g 45 stuff to prevent nt4 remains
weak
okay I didn't do this - well I think
looks a little bit oh maybe I didn't do
this too - well hmm Thanks
I'm 55 there is a chick when he aged
hmm I'm not so happy about all this this
should be six oh hey look
rook e8 was a lot lotta fun
I was a lot tougher to break down I
think
yeah maybe it was a what else scenario
okay come on maybe this isn't much
technically but it should be enough
[Music]
it's got a fairly good block a jump but
at the end there will be like g7 and
King is 7 and then the pawns will will
go I think it was always winning to be
honest there's the statement that black
messed up I don't think he could have
saved that one I just had just too many
points
not exactly quick really not quick
wow-whee it was really close
absolutely close okay so let's go route
g6 yeah I can I can go away I think it
was no stalemate
[Music]
hmmm what's going on with this that's a
pretty pretty weird
opening play I could go eat six yeah I
think I will it's pretty difficult now
for him to develop so it's their queen
bee three threatens mage
and resigns
yeah Bishop takes h6 and Bishop f7 chick
okay so let's go form what challenges I
have a question probably a silly
question the city question is why what
is what is so useful about having a
discord
yeah so it can do a little bit more than
the twitchchat
yeah
okay I'm stopping further before me yeah
I think is I'm always a little bit
skeptical to get to get more let's say
platforms into the play and like I
already yea don't like to have yeah
those are those social media platforms I
I don't I don't really want to set up so
many loose ends
yeah so here I'm trying to trade off
this Bishop as always good get rid of
the English Bishop on g2 d4 is good you
feel I get told much I don't I don't
really think
now see seven small small fish but I
have to admit I didn't see that move it
was there was a little bit I was a
little bit too a little bit too
superficial there
[Music]
yeah I mean Facebook is really something
that I feel I should sometimes I just
feel I should delete the damn thing and
delete my account because it feels so
utterly pointless the only reason I keep
it is to keep in touch with what yeah
work make maids from from back in the
day when I was working in in the bank
because that's a good way to keep in
touch many of them have Facebook and you
kind of yeah sometimes learn what
they're doing and so it's nice nice and
I don't believe I don't don't see how I
could put that um I don't see how I
could migrate that let's say into a
different platform Wow then I will take
yeah thanks for the game a right kids my
worst troll I didn't really really have
anybody already terrible no I don't have
any grandmaster knows not even been
close do I get this again the Colorado
no yeah my favorite no I'm a good
alternative way to keep in touch with my
old mates that I would definitely kill
the Facebook account
no I was in IT controling in the bank so
no one genuine a bank business let's say
and no a right can play to play quite
okay I think I only made this blunder at
the end I feel the way this is set up
there could be there could be some
tactic going with the Bishop f6 and so
on well I did not did not think about
this move this one maybe join for Queen
h4
Bishop c8 was probably not too bad
there should be end of game I hope
yeah a good question by cheque to the
king how to find the right plan say in a
position yeah
yeah if you if you solve this one this
is this issue you'll be really strong
player the the main thing is that people
strong players rarely find plans they
just know nobody's correct simply by
knowing patterns so quite often that
would have an immediate idea like okay
in this kind of situation this would be
a normal move and then they will often
play one of those ideas that feel normal
to them the really great solutions are
the ones that don't really am
it relates directly to a new pattern
this is always when when I'm really when
I really think a move was fantastically
good that must be a move that as some I
must be move that is like completely
opposed to what I would expect or just a
solution way I feel okay this is really
original creative oh you're not playing
okay I usually know the patterns by yeah
playing and studying it's both
I mean you can't challenge me but I
don't know if you if this will work out
in the session Ida sky I decided to know
not to draw I decided to stream a little
bit longer and do the Texas later
yeah playing this in a very solid
fashion white lookout
it seemed Bishop c2 is played most often
I think
yeah the sound I think is probably quite
quite good I mean it's a wait let me
think about this for just a moment
[Music]
yeah I have a decent microphone in it I
just put it closer to me so I usually
had it a little bit further away from me
and now I think it's better it's more
closely positioned so I'm okay before
how do I play this it's a blue area
yeah stopping any further b5 pushes
yeah this position type is always
difficult for me first glance you you
think black must be fine but when you
look at this you kind of begin to
appreciate that
white is actually in pretty good shape
yeah I don't like this position
convenience not it's not very good I
think with black this is kind of a move
that shows that I have no clue nice cut
yeah in the c5 is weak and so on
it was a good move as well
[Music]
now I don't like it this is not good I
have a hard time yet you move knight c6
cannot move the knight on f6 cannot move
d4 is impossible okay this is the this I
should have done one move earlier if I
wanted to do it but I was simply running
out of ideas I have issues with this
opening anyway the Italian here with d3
their white is very okay now it is
strongly four and five stuff to blame
[Music]
yeah my position is pretty bad nice got
Bishop f7 Knight takes rook takes Bishop
f7 I'm lost
the the bad thing is it's it's almost
impossible to win on time because it's
increment this is always slight hope
[Music]
I know I could resign but somehow
yeah well taking the night was not bad
technically speaking
[Music]
whoo-chow
what can you do what can you do
Plus 650 yeah and that sets it with my
2,300 play some friggin 1500 new account
okay
so team or it's four plus one may I play
pretty badly this game so I don't want
to complain too much
okay so here we have an F for opening
bird opening let's see T moist is
combined c4 and F Wyatt it's a bit bit
rare I should have taken on c4 actually
okay so here I try to
I try to treat this bishop
but Bishop a3 did not work so I'm just
going to centralize 94-88 and then see
what happens yeah I'm just going with
the flu drew a product you will not play
where so many before you in the list and
I definitely have to stop in on in 30
minutes
because then it's time time for dinner
as simply and that I cannot delay yeah
probably not play the Provisionals
I mean you get the rating back if it if
it was a cheater but it's still a
completely pointless thing to do
okay he tried so much t g7 me as always
if you have such a game and you don't
quite know what that was here was that
foul play or not it's kind of I know
what did I it's kind of it always yeah
kind of it kind of
yeah kilts the flow a little bit
I don't know yet what I'll have for
dinner I would have to check what what's
in my fridge reading this we are a
couple of minutes before before 5:00
p.m. I have different boarded pieces no
I don't think so I'm understandably
chess set at the moment I had something
here from what was that called
and I always forget stylish yes I had
some some stylish sets but people said
they look Murray on stream so I switched
to a standard set and it's it's fine
[Music]
yeah this endgame is a little bit more
comfortable for me
I think somebody sent it to me I don't
quite remember who that was and I'm
really sorry sorry about that thanks for
all those fellows what is yessir doing
on there it's playing the computer in
crazy house must be crazy house
so I'm trying to win this ending d4
would have been interesting yeah okay
for yeah okay for was better you're
completely right g5 was Bolivian move
yeah I know I should get to pass SB porn
and see porn yeah thanks for the game
team oh um so we've got Phoenix on
Phoenix 89 so this is five minutes of
this game maybe one more and I
definitely have to run
I am going to go see five and stop
everything there before was a trolley
good move as he is quite hydrated
it's not a pretty a pretty nice position
for white odeerforce normally you need
to open this production up and get some
more some more space if is completely
completely no normal in this kind of
position you get these six for example I
don't have any pets now
yeah viewercount is good how many of us
do we have has it been
is it including like 100-something or
what do we have or I'll take another
form yeah the main issues for discord
has kept pictures yeah well this is even
on Facebook and these are the posts that
are probably most enjoyable for me
actually
wonder about 9f5 in 9f5 would have been
interesting the best player that I've
that I've beaten as my guru which at the
time he was rated roughly 2600 and he
was high I was number 5 in the world at
some point at that time he wasn't such
an super active tournament player
anymore so just know he won 96 93 what
do you play as black I don't know
he fired from me that's probably the
best move transposed to e 45
this is difficult now for him age six
less Queen to f6 King age seven Bishop
b4 check
I don't think I played naca red and
bullets maybe when he was a kid and I
don't remember I played some blitz games
okay and it tries to go Queen Jeff form
but I should prevent it and Ruby five is
good anyway oh I should have prevented
it I mean I'm still winning but it was
probably possible to prevent it and then
that this is preferable play for mate
yeah and that that was Phoenix's
resignation so close to a three hours
stream here I would play it's a bullet
challenge one bullet challenge I would
take yeah thanks for the game
Phoenix 89 give me like one bullet
challenge I will play the one bullet
game and then close the stream anybody
around up form one bullet game doesn't
look like it I don't see any bullet
challenge this one Kooyong here we go
yeah hey white is just I'm going to be
eternally better that's not very
exciting but cannot do much at all I
mean white is also not really able to do
much okay
it was kind of it was kind of
anti-climatic that stencil would okay
guys we are on exactly three hours funny
enough
and I hope you enjoyed the stream it
wasn't intended to be that long word
somehow the Nexus did not feel too
tempting to do and I have to do an enemy
thanks for watching
I'll be back soon as my wife